I want to jump to the Meg sequel okay
which is something I cannot wait to see
good uh let's talk about the sequel how
has it been testing what are you looking
forward to fancying well
you know I think for a lot of people the
original movie was a surprise how well
it did
um and what I find so wonderful is how
much people still talk about it you know
what are we four years later now I think
something like that so it's really held
its appeal
um so we tried to uh in making this
movie
you know one of the things we learned is
you could add more comedy than we
originally thought in a shark movie in a
way so I think this movie's probably
funnier there's certainly some big
laughs in it
um we have more creatures uh we
introduce you to another level of of
um you know really dangerous creatures
uh We've also added a phenomenal star in
Wu Jing who's a Chinese movie star who
is just such a really wonderful Guy and
um and he and Jason have a really
interesting chemistry
um and it really explores
same universe in a way but we're pushing
the experience of it for sure there's
more shark attacks there's more crazy
ideas that we've tested out on the
audience and and so it's proven out to
be
um I think the movies it's testing well
but more importantly uh
the audience seems to be relating to it
very similar to the first movie yeah the
footage I saw I was like howling I mean
there's a thing where the shark breaks
through the glass and eats a social
influencer I'm like yes and bring this
on you know um so uh I'm curious with it
I feel like that how much does the MPAA
push back on anything or how much are
they sort of saying we this is like
cartoony they push back on the blood
as long as you don't do Gore
they they sort of accept the the the fun
nature of it you know and I think
because of the fun nature it takes the
edge off it a little bit but at the same
time the movie needs to have some Edge
you know or else it feels like it
becomes a spoof or something and that's
definitely not what it is so it it's
been a I think the trickiest thing about
the Megs is keeping that balance between
violence and humor look I I mean the
concept of Jason punching sharks is
fantastic that's a plus and you know
what I mean that's that's what I want to
see is so I will ask does Jason punch a
shark or a creature in the face in the
movie because that's what I'm paying to
say well not exactly but maybe we topped
that idea he might tap in a really
violent way uh he kicks a shark I'm okay
with that that's still a bot that's
still an attack absolutely you know um
what was it though that was it covid
what was it that took so long because
the first one was a big hit to get the
sequel made and to get it in theaters I
don't know I was trying to find that
Second Story
you know and sometimes it comes really
easy and sometimes it doesn't uh because
it's a co-production also you have the
Chinese gravity pictures and you have
Warner Brothers and they didn't see eye
to eye exactly where we were going so it
took a while to get them to agree
in a way to go back to the the
experience that we had on the first
movie so uh that took a while I'm
assuming this is one of those hour and a
half to two hour movies it is definitely
under two hours I do my best
to to respect my audience and not go
past that yes uh and I think it's
somewhere around uh 150 an hour and 50.
now that the sequel was made assuming
the sequel is a hit I'm already gonna
say are you already thinking about where
it can go because this could be you know
a franchise just Jason you know what I
mean could be yeah
um
I think we we can tell some more fun
stories for sure you know I I think the
challenge will be
um
how to find in a way another Underwater
World to
to explore that'll be the now my gut
says that's the thing we'll need to
figure out so it doesn't feel like
you're going to the same place over and
over again you know this time we go so
much more time there so it feels
different
like you're really in there for a long
stretch of the movie so you get to know
it in a way and you run into structures
that
people don't know are down there and
things that are you know it's going to
surprise you uh and surprise the
characters so uh but I think a third
time there might feel like we're
overstating our welcome so I think
that'll be the task the next time is to
figure out what is that next Underworld
water experience that you want to find
it'll be uh the Meg versus GI Joe and
Transformers